the prestige proved even further that
Christopher Nolan wasn't a director to
ignore years later we still can't get
over the film's central twists which
like a true magician no than hid in
plain sight he is how he pulled off the
trick everything in the prestige plays
fairly with the audience regarding the
central trick the ending is telegraphed
repeatedly through nearly every
character and every line making it one
of the most surprising and paradoxically
most foreshadowed twists and movie
history it's all summed up in the
opening narration by John cutter where
he breaks down the trick into three acts
the pledge the turn and the prestige
you're looking for the senior but you
won't find because your cooks
[Music]
as cutting the rates the camera pans
over a series of identical birds one of
whom he chooses to meet disappear and
then reappear as a prestige part of the
trick
we'll see this bird trick later when
Sara brings her nephew to a magic show
which causes him to burst into tears at
the thought of the birds death surprise
is Alfred Borden to hear the question
about the birds brother not just because
a child can see through the trick
because it's his trick the central twist
of the movie Borden is fellin each a
twin living half of a life sharing the
spotlight at the beginning of the film
and gia reads a passage from Borden's
diary and the audience is given its
first glimpse into what triggered the
pair's long-standing feud
Borden's narration here is easily able
to trick the audience we were two young
men at the star of a crow Korea two
young men devoted to an illusion two
young men never intended to hurt anyone
the audience is prone to think that this
narration refers to Borden and an gia
based on the premise of the movie but
that's not right Borden and an Gia never
devote themselves to an illusion Borden
and Fallon do they've devoted themselves
to the illusion that has only one Borden
and that they never intended to hurt
anyone is true and Gia's first move
against Borden involves a loaded pistol
so the implication that the two young
men who never intended harm are Borden
and Anne gia is dismissed within the
next thirty minutes of screen time the
movie wastes no time in telling you
exactly what's happening but it's so
obvious you can't help but be swept
along if you're not paying attention
after angeas wife escapes the water tank
Borden and gia and cutter discuss their
different philosophies on magic a real
magician tries to invent something new
that other magicians are gonna scratch
their heads over you know when cutter
asks him if he has such a trick Borden
says he does but he refused to sell it
as no one else can do it
this scene serves a variety of purposes
firstly it shows how cutter knows a
business well enough to shoot down
Borden's every idea for being reckless
but it also shows how desperate Borden
is to create a trick that specifically
confuses other magicians as the two men
discuss money and selling tricks and gia
doesn't say much content to just watch
cutter and Borden are working-class
people whose jobs depend on their own
but Angie egg comes from money and
doesn't feel the need to engage
tellingly the audience doesn't figure
into that conversation Kota keeps
mentioning money or borden pushes for
the act of creation performance and
magic is a highest ideal something only
other magicians can understand to
confuse another practitioner is the
highest praise and an Jia will spend the
rest of the film suitably scratching his
head over Borden's transported mantric
cutter sells Angie Erin Borden that if
they want to see what it takes to do
real magic they need to go see Chung
Ling soo who can make a full fish tank
appear on stage Borden and Angie ago and
afterwards the pair watched the old man
daughter into a cab this is the truth
this is a performance why this is why
Noah came to take this movie as he
speaks the camera zooms into borden's
face to underscore the seriousness of
what he's saying we're watching a
confession Borden recognizing a fellow
practitioner willing to shape his entire
life around the performance of magic
once again he never mentions the
audience only the art the sacrifice is
empowering for him to see that his trick
can work later on gia will show off the
trick for his wife Julia but he does it
half mockingly in disbelief that anyone
could or would want to do it something
Wharton sort of wants me I couldn't
fathom him live my whole life pretending
to be someone else it's a key
foreshadowing of why an Jia would be the
only one who can't believe Portland uses
a double a self-sacrifice they're
pretending he emits right there that
it's unthinkable to him when Julia
drowns in the water tank and gia becomes
obsessed with finding out the truth
behind which not Borden used to tie her
wrists and able to accept that bored and
cannot remember it's a question that
hangs over the men throughout the film
with bored and confessing finally that
even he would never know I have fought
with myself over that night when alpha
me swam blind I tried a simple Slipknot
the other half convinced that I tied the
Langford double board and can give
angira simple answer about which knotty
tied because the twins trade off on
different days one twin would have tied
the simple nuts the other would have
tied the Langford double but bored and
can't say whether he knows whether it's
aboard and who tied the knots or the
board and who truly doesn't know which
knotty tied the illusion requires
self-sacrifice of all the characters and
the prestige Sara comes the closest to
realizing Borden as two people she tells
bored and early
in the film that she can tell he doesn't
always mean it when he says he loves her
more in love with magic than me I like
being able to tell the difference it
makes the the day's it is true means
something the surviving boarder and the
one who confesses to nga the secret is
the one who loves Sarah the other board
and it's the one who falls in love with
Olivia but at this point in the film
he's not with anyone else so Sarah
guesses that he's in love with magic
instead this is also when Fallon enters
a picture
prompting concern from Sarah that they
don't have enough to pay him a clever
reference to Fallon sharing half of
everything with Borden immediately
before Sarah tells him that they're
going to have a baby
we should tell Fallon that it's great
we're having a baby the way in that
sentence is deceptive since it seems
like he's talking about himself and
Sarah but he's really referencing Fallon
/ other Borden - they're all having a
baby together
since they shared everything each living
half a life which includes Sarah and
their daughter when Borden begin sharing
his transported man and gia becomes
obsessed with her although cutter
insists it's done with a double and gia
is convinced otherwise the audience
should believe cutter since he's
consistently shown to be wise and
knowledgeable later after Olivia and
Borden begin their affair she tells on
gia that she found disguised materials
not used for the show at times boring
couldn't possibly be watching we should
be listening to these characters but
we're too caught up in angeas passion
his attempt to duplicate the trick
involves him hiring a double of his own
Jerald roots also played by Jackman in a
slight nod to Borden's true secret route
as sleazy and alcoholic with too much
pride and not enough to live for a
disturbing mirror - the vices are an
Gaea dabbles with throughout the film
though root is played by Jackman he
can't possibly live like Borden does
with his trick it rankles an Jia to
spend his prestige huddled underneath
the stage while his double takes a bow
he's jealous of himself in a way Borden
can never be a self-sacrifice demanded
of real magic too much for him
it pushes him to send Olivia to him for
trade Borden's trusts leading to
disaster for everyone until one of the
Borden twins falls in love with Olivia
they united in their desires they
achieve success a family and the art
they dreamed of but once they fracture
it leads to strife and Gia kidnaps
Fallon and buries him to get the cipher
for a fake notebook of
thinking this will lead him to the
secret behind the transported man
it won't of course but the point of the
scene is our Fallon's near-death
encounter leads one of the Borden twins
to arrive to a dinner date with Sarah
stinking drunk with Olivia along for the
ride today I thought that something very
precious I've been lost this line is in
reference to the other board and twins
near-death experience but regardless the
platens appearance of Olivia pushes
Sarah towards alcoholism and eventually
ends with her taking her own life when
she can't stand the Borden's lies
anymore the openness with which boarding
conducts his affair with Olivia brings
to the fore all the repressed feelings
Sarah was able to push down forcing her
to kill herself rather than fully betray
Borden and reveal his secret of all of
the plot points in the film otezla and
his cloning machine received the most to
region while it's true that the science
fiction Edition is a surprise it serves
a few important points first Tesla and
Edison rivalry mirrors and year
importance continuing the motif of
reflections and doubles that pervades
the movie seconds it's symbolic of the
corruption of an GA as a magician he's
not disappearing and bringing himself
back the way to turn in the prestige
require he's just copying himself over
and over killing himself in a sickening
penance for the death of his wife in the
same manner finally in his own way and
Jerris ultimately proven right in his
assertion that every trick can be
duplicated by cloning himself he's able
to duplicate the ultimate trick of poor
Dan's act the use of an identical twin
the difference between them is that he'd
rather kill his twin that live his life
pretending to be someone he's not Angie
arrives aboard and cell to gloat and
tear apart the secret to the transported
man that it's so obsessed over
throughout the entire movie boarding
gives Fallon a tearful goodbye admitting
that he was right they should have left
Angie alone
it's the closest the two brothers get to
openly speaking to each other with
Borden apologizing for the way his
affair with Olivia led to Sarah's death
Borden's escorted to the hangman's noose
Maryse asked about his final words he
disappears but that's not magic
you can't just make something disappear
you have to bring it back Borden Xu
Sanjaya standing alone in a hole of his
drowned clones and lays out the truth he
was Fallon and Fallon's was Borden the
two men sharing one life he reiterate
that that's what magic curse of the art
requires devotion and sacrifice a
sacrifice an Jia could never match all
this he tells him was for nothing and
Jia tells Borden that he never
understood why they did this knows that
an Jia goes on to explain that if you
have the ability to make an audience
wonder in spite of this then you got to
see something very special it's a direct
plea to the audience straight from
writers Christopher and Jonathan Nolan
but the ability to trick the audience to
make them imagine a world like their own
but difference that exists right at
their fingertips Borden says earlier in
the film that a secret impresses no one
but we're not so sure some tricks are
even more impressive when you see the
self sacrifice a total devotion to the
art check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite films are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]